this is Startalk here we go
D Creek deep secret Jesus with a trick
Dietrich Thank You Dietrich in swig
wants to know this o Quyet Dietrich in
swig
kiya that's the name right okay di kaya
di kya says do it yourself kind of do
you there you go let's see why I'm sorry
you carry on all right now hello mr. Nye
do you foresee the GMOs will be the sole
food source at the grocery stores
anytime soon meaning will food be so
difficult to come by as the population
grows it's exponentially that all food
will have to be modified in some way so
there could be grown and harvested in
widespread locations well in other words
are we headed towards Soylent Green yeah
but it's not people the answer is we're
already there
Oh not to get too weird on you but
everything that you eat with very few
exceptions I mean you might wander
through the occasional forest and eat a
nut or I remember I there were some wild
blackberries that I encountered often as
a kid you'll eat those but generally
everything you eat is from a farm where
people over the last 10,000 years have
hybridized modified selected
artificially or induced choosing of the
offspring so that we got these the foods
that we all enjoy today so the answer is
we're already there not to be dismissive
just that taking genes from one organism
and putting them in another for farming
it's what we're doing now which happens
in nature from time to time these
viruses work their way into the genes of
the classic as the sweet potatoes this
is happening naturally so we're just
doing it carefully and diligently and
fast and that's how we're able to feed
so many people all right now here's an
addendum to that question I'm pleased
I'm going to speak on behalf of choice
Co yes
so is there possibility or a danger of
centralizing our food
source in such a concentrated fashion
where we harm ourselves by giving too
much power to the people that feed the
world
I think psychologically there's a real
fear amongst people of that being the
case so is it I think I know what you
mean is it a corporation that you're
afraid of
yes that's my point man okay but you're
not exactly afraid of a farmer no I'm
not afraid of a farmer because if I
don't like my little upstate farmer guy
I'm like all right well screw you
upstate farmer guy I'm gonna go to down
state farm Agabus but if the Upstate
farmer guy on the downstate farmer guy
are all one guy well maybe a little bit
of trouble now all right I get you so
bear in mind farmers make choices now
look what I sound like farmers make
choices they can buy seeds from this guy
or that guy all right and like
everything else do you remember Gateway
computers yes everything else things
have gotten consolidated because of
international commerce has made it more
efficient and I understand our fear of
corporations but nevertheless that is
manageable through dare I say it
regulation yeah where you would make it
so that the marketplace is generally
fair so this is seems like a very
solvable problem but I am not worried
about the man taking over the world
because farmers make choices and
producing seeds with certain
characteristics it's very competitive
business and so it'll and the sieve
being one example this will remain this
will be the way it is you know roundup
is a famous brand yes it is I have some
in my basement I hate to say but there
are dozens of country companies several
of them are in Asia that manufacture a
very similar glyphosate salt that is
well suited as an herbicide gotcha so
it's a competitive business alright just
that the glyphosate thing was so
successful that everybody embraced it
home gardener and farm industrial farmer
alike this
is Startalk